so where we're at is to say this is what
you already know if I know you're here
and I hope it's starting to like oh yeah
this universe this is okay it's coming
back to you slowly
maybe quickly if you're doing well okay
now what is the point of what can we
build on this right what can we do with
this that we haven't already done where
we're going to kick off in the double
today we'll see where we go during that
double but the first thing we start off
with is something called greatest
coefficient so we know that we've got a
whole bunch of coefficients that appear
from a binomial expansion well what we
want to work out in this context is
which one is the biggest one now that
might seem especially when you look at
something like this all right see me I
can trigger your question and you're
like isn't it just just that one and the
answer is what we're going to give you
situations in which it's not just easy
to just point and say it's the one in
the middle right we're talking about
situations where it slightly differs
where'd it grow from greatest
coefficient to also looking at the
greatest term what is the difference
between a coefficient and a term well in
the context of binomials right here is
the coefficient here is the term right
so it's what happens when you ball
everything together particularly when
you actually start to look at not just
um not just pronumerals
not just algebra in there but when you
put numerical values on those things
okay now we then move forward a little
bit we've got more things to have a look
at so we are going to just like we had a
look at trigonometric identities back in
trig term to last year we're gonna have
a look at binomial identities and these
are much the same you'll be required to
prove like you remember how it worked in
trig identities you would have to you'll
be given a left-hand side a right-hand
side and it would look like this
complicated mess and you had to use your
your knowledge of trigonometry to sort
of geometric functions to find some
equivalents right we're going to do
exactly the same thing with all of this
language okay
after binary identities we're going to
put binomial together with some of the
our favorite things from the past which
we have known about but we haven't gone
into how they apply to binomial theorem
because we hadn't developed that
knowledge so for instance we have
treated this kind of like this is all
whole number lived right one
five 10 5 10 5 1 etc what you get from
Pascal's triangle so this is gets really
far away from calculus which is all
about not whole numbers but little parts
of numbers right but we are going to put
binomial theorem together with calculus
so we're going to be differentiating
integrating these things we are also
going to put Bible through together with
one of our topics from last term namely
induction because you get series and
sequences out of these things right
which we did induction with so we're
going to be putting those together and
the last thing which we are actually
probably not I'd say include in these
couple of weeks because we do all of the
probability after trials we are going to
look at how all of this applies to
questions of chance so we call this
binomial probability so this is in cases
where I'll just give you a quick tease
if you do something many many times
right but there are only two options for
whether you you for example you win or
you lose a match or you flip heads or
tails
but you then do that many many times
like hundreds of times okay then what
happens is those probabilities they
stack up with powers right like if I say
what's the probability of flipping a
coin ten times in a row and getting
heads every single time you'd say that's
1/2 to the power of tip because you
multiply probabilities successively
every time you have a new stage we see
if powers are getting into play here and
there are only two alternatives that in
fact binomials are a perfect way to
understand these things so this is where
we are headed
during the double we're going to kick
off with this greatest coefficient
business so thank you for your work now
enjoy the rest of your morning and we'll
see you after recess right so hopefully
that's enough story time now why have I
asked you to have a go at these three
well number one good to wake you up I
know this morning is kind of like it's
been so long over a year since we've had
a look at binomial theorem now these are
pretty stock standing questions
in fact just if we wanted to give you a
1 mark binomial theorem question this is
exactly what we would ask but what I
want to point out for you here is an
interesting pattern ok I'm already
flagged for you in periods you that zero
we're going to talk about this idea here
looking at the coefficients in
particular looking for the one that is
biggest in size have a look here at
which one is biggest for the first one
because you start off with a really nice
simple expansion you didn't even need to
write the thing down to know which of
the coefficients would be the greatest
which one is it it's the six in this
case which unsurprisingly is in the
middle of the series okay no big deal
one four six four one as you expect
Pascal's triangle is symmetrical so you
will either get one or two and they will
always be in the middle okay but when
you have a look at question 2 in
question 3 you can see this changes yeah
there are five terms each time and for
this series here the greatest
coefficient is not the middle term the
greatest coefficient is what is it it's
the second one it's some 1,500 there
right so this is the greatest
coefficient and then if you have a look
at the last one the greatest coefficient
is not the middle it's not even a little
bit it's the very first term right and
you can see if I had you know if I'd
switch these around or adjusted the
numbers we can have a series in
expansion where the greatest coefficient
is any particular term okay so shut this
down for me right so we can capture like
summarize what's the point what's what's
the generalization of what we've just
demonstrated here okay here would be
what I would say for for a plus B to the
power of n right any number you like I
didn't have to pick four I just wanted
to be tricky enough that there was so
complexity but also small enough you
could just do it fairly easily for a
plus B to the end the greatest
coefficient would be the middle term or
terms right so the greatest coefficient
will be the middle term or the middle
terms if there are two of them right
like we were looking this morning at 1 5
10 10 5 1 so the two 10s they would be
the greatest coefficients but they are
still there in the middle okay so that's
just generally speaking but
as you can see if a and B take on values
where there are numerical kind of
components to these that interact with
the binomial coefficients let me say
that again okay if a and B have some
kind of numerical component like a five
or a three or six right those numbers
when you expand them out they kind of
play around with the one four six four
one right and so you can see here
because the five is bigger than the
three rather than being kind of like a
nice symmetrical they get bigger they
get smaller right here they kind of like
they get bigger faster and then they get
smaller and they sort of taper off right
so your greatest term is no longer in
the middle its kind of leading over and
then here it's it's even more extreme
you start at the greatest coefficient
and then the coefficients just get
smaller it's more than smaller does that
make sense so these kinds of shapes here
are either straight what's happening as
you change these kinds of numbers right
so unless a and B have numerical
components right so if they're just
purely algebraic a B who knows what they
are right you'll always be in the middle
but what we're interested in is when
they are not just in the middle if a and
B have some kind of numerical component
then that will interact with your
regular or binomial coefficient okay
so as you can imagine we are not
particularly interested in these because
they're so trivial we're interested in
these guys where it starts to get
interesting